okay let me think of another why we're
back okay
hi i'm ron funches from film and
television and also where everyday life
here are some videos that I very much
enjoy I hope you like them too
I like to watch a baby that's excited to
see his mommy but it's too sleepy
it's that epic battle we all fight some
days between being excited to see the
person we love and also excited to just
get out of this consciousness it's a fun
thing to see this next video is just
full of high impact intensity I love it
it's for my boy down and receipt of pro
wrestling guerrilla I love watching them
just fight throughout the Ring sometimes
they flip out into the crowd and they
crush you
and I feel like you could sue them cuz I
don't think they're taking accurate
security measures this next video just
mixes two of my favorite things gangster
rap and the Muppets I'm about to ruin
the image in a style that you're used to
it's gonzo singing the Humpty dance what
else could you want it's a great video
it makes me laugh it's just a fun time
for everyone
[Music]
the next video just makes me feel for my
fuzzy inside it's what I think of when I
think of just love it's a porcupine in
the pumpkin you never thought you wanna
see this but you do and you're watching
for hours I did you should live in my
world enjoy this video
well I'm Ron Funches I hope you enjoyed
my videos I hope they changed your life
let's do it again